today on drew in a daytime exclusive
there was no higher career calling card
than
to work with woody allen this is
too personal for human consumption
whatever's going on now is not the sum
of your entire life
there is this darkness deep
deep inside it all starts now
welcome everyone our first guest is the
main subject in the harrowing
documentary allen versus pharaoh
in which she leaves no stone left
unturned
bearing it all about the abuse she says
she endured as a child
it is important to note that woody allen
has never been criminally charged
in connection with these allegations to
say this story has a very complicated
history
is an understatement please take a look
the new hbo docu-series allen versus
pharaoh
examines the abuse allegations involving
famed director
woody allen this series revolves around
dylan
farrow the adopted daughter of actress
mia faro
and woody allen raised by someone
considered to be a
treasure of the cinema dylan's childhood
was once seen as idyllic to the outside
world but in 1992
when abuse allegations were raised that
all changed
alan denies child abuse woody gave a
press conference
and our jaws dropped no matter what you
think you know
it's just the tip of the iceberg
dividing her family
hollywood and the public dylan's claims
of abuse and the latest interviews
bring us into her past trauma with the
aid of her brother
ronan and her mother's perspectives new
footage and recordings are shared
in this documentary seemingly supporting
the claims made by the then
seven-year-old dylan he made me feel so
special
that's where things get really really
complicated
because
threaded throughout all of those good
times there was
a lot more going on
woody allen and his wife sunyi also an
adopted daughter
of mia have consistently denied these
allegations stating that they are
quote categorically false it's taken me
a long time
to sort of reconcile that you can love
somebody and be afraid of them
an adult now dylan remains adamant in
her disclosures that she has repeatedly
stated for the past
20 years she now uses her platform to
try and teach
other survivors to be brave and
resilient
themselves
i'm very honored to welcome the very
brave
dylan farrow
[Applause]
i feel like you look so different in
person do i oh my god i have all my
makeup on i like
normally i'm like if you saw me crawl
into work every morning
i look like someone they wouldn't let in
the building
and not the same way there was a very
nice girl who
came to the hotel and she did it ahead
of time
and it was really cute my daughter got
to see all of her makeup stuff she was
very
enamored of that so you know
our life is in chapters and i think we
should hold this conversation especially
in honor of you being
an incredible novelist oh my god
with your brand new book out called hush
um
i think i would love to conduct this
conversation if i may in a writerly way
to honor
your beautiful career and because
i do believe that life is a book with
many chapters
i want to say first out of the gate too
that
i uh i would like to explain myself
uh because this is not about me but i
wanted to
sort of have this type of candor i
worked with woody allen
i did a film with him in 1996 called
everyone says i love you
and um there was no higher
career calling card than to work with
woody allen
and then i had children
and it changed me
because i realized that i was
one of the people who was basically
gaslit
into not looking
at a narrative beyond what i was being
told
and i see what's happening in the
industry now
yeah and that is because of you making
that brave
choice so thank you
for that thank you oh my goodness
hearing what you just said
like i mean i i'm trying not to cry
right now um
but like it it it just just so
meaningful
because it's easy for me to say like of
course you shouldn't work with him you
know
he's a jerk he's a monster but i just
find it
incredibly brave and
incredibly generous that
that you would say to me that um
that my story and what what i what i
went through
was important enough to you to to
reconsider that
absolutely and
how hard was it for you
to engage in this documentary which i
really want to make a caveat
about that your family did not produce
no no they came to us i think that's
very important for people to understand
your family did not produce this
documentary we participated
and apparently everyone was asked to
participate
yeah no they they they went to everyone
um and and and that was important you
know
even just to me to know that like that
there was
a level of journalistic integrity at
work here so
did your family get together and say
these people are different they're
taking a tone they're using a diligence
there there's a thoroughness here
that feels safer in order to come out
and make this brave decision um
i was actually the one who initially
told my mom and told ronan you know like
hey you know i sat down with with these
people and i really think
that they are on the up and up so then
when my mom
agreed to be interviewed i was really
really shocked
and when ronan agreed i was even more
shocked and then
fletcher agreed and i was i mean i was
picking my jaw up off the floor
and you know gradually more and more of
my siblings signed on and a few of them
didn't and i've spoken to them about
that
too and i i respect that decision as
well
um but i mean in terms of like
a family meeting not really but
um but there was there was communication
and interestingly the the documentary
has led to
greater communication between us as a
result i think which is interesting
may i ask why you were surprised that
they signed on
i think mostly because
we wouldn't talk about it to each other
so talking about it
publicly it was just
it just seemed absolutely
incomprehensible okay
um we're gonna take a quick commercial
break and
when we come back more with dylan
welcome back to a very important and
honest conversation with
dylan farrow you know
how did your mom feel watching
the documentary i mean it was tough
because
i would have loved to have been able to
watch the series with her
um and at the time that just
wasn't possible we were we were in
separate quarantine pods
unfortunately um
so i really sort of heard everything
from her
after the fact you know it was just a
very
strange pathway that we
navigated separately and together
but i think it it definitely changed
a lot about how we how me and my mom
relate to each other and interact with
each other and
i think there's a very renewed
level of just respect
just woman to woman
i mean sometimes when i think back
on memories of my life there has like
a gauze a patina a sort of
surrealist reverie
i know mentally that time has gone by
but i also can feel like i can
be back there in a moment's notice like
that
um even if it does feel almost
watching a home movie and then
when you were watching the home movie
of you what did you think and feel
and remember it was a really
bizarre psychological experience for me
honestly because
i had the video in my house
um i gave it to my husband
and i just said put it into sort of like
the darkest corner that you can find
just know where it is and that
moment of just in case happened when
i was talking to amy and she asked
if she could see slash use the video in
the series and
my first reaction was like absolutely
not
like no i draw the line here this is too
much it is too personal
i don't want to see the video i don't
want anybody else to see this video
and amy
i don't know how she talked me into it
she managed to get
the video taken i i had my husband
bring it out of that dark corner of
wherever he stashed it in the closet
and we watched it
on someone's computer and
my husband had to leave the room he was
like i can't
this is like this is too much and
i was just like completely numb i
watched the entire thing as though i was
watching
someone else just a little girl who
looked kind of like me who you know
sounded kind of like me
you know and i just completely
disassociated
from it and you know they went on their
way i was like
please just you know let me think over
using this and a week went by almost
like exactly
and i was sitting in my house and i just
suddenly burst into tears
and it just it hit me everything from
the tape just
i mean it punched me right in the face
and i was just sobbing uncontrollably
for like a couple of days on and off
about what i saw and just sort of
trying to mentally
reconcile the fact
that that little girl on the tape
was me and she was talking about
something that happened to me
and it was
overwhelming it's very
difficult sometimes to know
that that part of me
is such
a dark painful place
i mean because when i look at my life
now i have a wonderful husband i have a
wonderful daughter i have a wonderful
life and
i'm really excited about you know my
career writing
and you know taking my daughter to
kindergarten next year
and all the all the wonderful things
that
surround me and yet there is this
impenetrable darkness deep
deep inside that
i mean i'm gonna be honest i just i
still don't know what to do with
wow okay so we're gonna take another
break
but when we come back i would really
love to talk to you
about not only finding love but being
able to trust
we'll be right back more with dylan
[Music]
farrell
we are back with dylan farrow
i would love to talk about your husband
how do you go from
having the life that you had and and not
being trepidatious but being emboldened
i really liked him i was i was very
smitten and
i felt confident that i wasn't
like asking for something ridiculous
because i've you know seen guys and i've
been like so
what do you think of moving this into
relationship territory and they
just like book it and at the time of
course i internalized that as like
oh well this is because i'm messed up um
and so you know how did you not do that
with your husband
that is a really good question i guess
it was because
i really liked him he did try to break
up with me
and a lot of that was because i had
hang-ups about sex so i think it was
when he tried to break up with me was
when i it's sort of crystallized
for me that this was something that i
wanted um this was something that i
wanted enough
to address the things that he was
talking about the issues
which was sex which was from trauma
which was
from things that i did not like to think
about so
in a lot of ways
it really i think it started me sort of
on that path to
looking inward and examining myself a
little bit more critically
so then did you overcome that hurdle i'm
guessing
it's an ongoing process i mean because
in a lot of in a lot of ways i feel like
sex hang-ups
are something that grow with us and it's
just sort of confronting
the issues as they arise and not getting
discouraged by them i guess
um i mean what is wrong with me has been
like my mantra across my life
and i'm trying to change it because it's
an outlook thing it's an attitude thing
and the fact that it's my knee-jerk
reaction
you know is because of trauma it's
because i
internalize things and i think that
everything is my fault and i think that
i'm a failure and i'm you know again
like what
the the person that i am when i'm tanked
so today
say that crops up it rears its ugly head
how do you whack em all that today what
would your inner dialogue be today to
thwart that demon
it's you know honestly i i wanna know
the answer to that question too because
it is a work in progress
and sometimes it does feel like i'm
flinging pennies at a battleship
and you know that there's
nothing i mean like that i can say
or do for myself to myself that will
change
anything because i'm stuck and yet
you're out there being brave
so what attempts did you make to reclaim
your life
you know like there are times when i'll
be
you know having a bad day and my
daughter will come home
from school and i'm just like okay no
now i am in mom mode i am
i am her mother now and
this this can't interfere with that i
can't let that interfere with
with her um because i don't want her i
don't want my problems to be her
problems
do you think that you're the most sane
when it comes to being a parent
i think being a parent has given me a
clarity
of being able to sort of
step outside of all the craziness in my
brain
and examine myself as who do i want this
person
to be that my little girl is going to
see
looking up to for her entire life
i i want her to think
you know my mom was a fighter and i want
her to think
you know my mom never gave up and my mom
didn't let crappy people bring her down
she you know she stood up to people she
stood up for the things that she
believed in the things she was she
thought was right
um and i want to be that person too do
you know that you take on
a very different energy when you talk
about being a parent
i love being a parent i love being i
love being evangeline's parent i
you know she is just
the light that she brings to my life is
indescribable
is it the best thing that's ever
happened to your life
yeah it really i mean
i'm very lucky i have a lot of good
things in my life and evangeline
i feel has just elevated that
when we come back more with dylan
we are back in conversation with dylan
farrow um how
do you deal with any fears that crop
up as a parent because i have mine from
my own history or my own stories or
things that are big triggers to me i
mean i i think about that a lot because
i do have things that trigger me in my
daily life
things that you know are probably just
like
completely stupid for other people that
just
send me completely down the spiral
and i'm actually kind of proud of myself
that i've gotten to the point where
i can
see a trigger or experience some sort of
trigger
i freeze and all that you know fun stuff
happens the
the emotions the the recall the
sensations and
i can process it
and sometimes it means waiting through
some of the negativity
how do you tell people to handle their
triggers if you see
an image i mean
i mean this happened to me like
last week maybe the week before i was
just you know scrolling through
my uh news feed and
an article pops up that
you know who and his his wife went to a
restaurant
and i was just tailspin
completely i was just like i can't
handle this i don't want to see this
like
why are they going to restaurants anyway
like
i was really very heavily triggered
and i was not okay and
it took a couple days
of me just sort of like
trying to like massage myself back into
a normal space can i ask do you
you know if people looking in who maybe
have not
experienced anything like this is it the
layers the repetition the many years
you watched the documentary and it's
it's
it's really i mean the unfairness of it
it's frustrating and then it makes me
feel
hopeless like like what was the point of
it and then
it's reminding myself of
facts that i know things that i can
tether to the documentary did accomplish
something i mean i think rain reported
that people were calling them at an
increased rate of like about 20
during the documentary which means that
survivors are out there connecting with
my story
and healing from it it's bittersweet
thinking you know like this story
is something that connects
a lot of survivors who are
hurting and
okay what more can we do for them like
how
how can we make this this world a space
that
women feel empowered or
feel at least less terrified
that is so well said thank you it really
is
what a perfect amazing answer to that
question
it's tough because like i wish that i
could say like here is
here is like you know a 10-step plan to
you know completely feeling healed and
fulfilled in your life
if you follow these steps you know
you're you're going to be just fine
i wish i had that what works for me
might not work for
somebody else so i think the best
the best advice that i offer is just
be true to yourself and
and and and and the truth that you have
lived
as a last question uh you turn
to fantasy writing i did um
what do you get out of creating these
fantasy worlds for yourself
and what do you want other people to get
from them
i think in a lot of ways seeing that
sort of veil of fantasy
is a very appealing way for me to sort
of
process stories that i stories that i
read how they relate to myself
sort of um understanding them a little
bit better
maybe you know it's a metaphor or an
allegory of like a dragon
because like dragons are dragons are
cool dragons are awesome
and dragons are also really scary i was
going to say they really
represent like the thing that you slay
yes
they are there to be overcome or
they will eat you alive yes and it's
a very it's the ultimate metaphor for
struggle is a dragon
in the metaphor of the book and the
closing
of that circle and that loop
what is your next chapter
well i'm actually really excited i
i've entered the editing phase
for the sequel to hush and
i'm looking at starting a whole new
writing project
and you know diving into something
completely different maybe
and also just you know continuing my
my little life in my little house with
my little family unit
and seeing seeing what else is on the
horizon i feel like
you know i feel like uh good things are
on the way
i think that is absolutely full of hope
full of strength thank you so much
um dylan farrow the four-part hbo
documentary
series allen versus pharaoh is available
on
hbo and hbo max and her book hush
is also available and apparently might
have a sequel
which is very exciting thank you
so much dylan for coming here this
conversation
everything i've been so looking forward
to it oh
seriously thank you thank you so much
everybody thank you so much and uh we'll
be back
[Music]
welcome back thank you you rock too
ma'am
and um thank you for that sign thank you
so much for all your signs drew's news i
love it and ma'am your beautiful baby
sleeping on your chest i mean come on
for all us parents gosh is that not the
best time
or what speaking of our next guest is
an amazing new mom and she comes from a
lineage of hollywood legends
um and political figures and
award-winning journalists
and yeah she was a part of a first
family of california family um
i think we're all madly in love with her
husband in a very platonic way
uh he's just like kind of all of our
heroes
um she is an aspca ambassador a new york
times
best-selling offer philanthropist and a
new mom please welcome
catherine schwarzenegger pratt
hi thank you for having me
how is it um your beautiful almost
one-year-old she yeah she just turned
nine months
um so it's i mean she's just
the cutest little angel i've ever seen
and i'm obsessed with her as i'm sure
most parents say about their children
um and it's the most fun
role and experience that i've ever had
and i love it absolutely every single
minute of it it's been such a joy she's
perfect
and um you are married to um chris
pratt who is just uh
i mean i've had luckily enough the
fortune and privilege of meeting him a
couple times he is always
the nicest human being he has the best
reputation
everybody loves him he's like the
coolest human
on the planet um when you met him
uh how long was it before you're like
you're the one
i mean we also we talk about that a lot
because i'm pretty sure we both
we both knew right away that that's
that you know this is where our
relationship was headed and we clicked
you know very quickly and um and so
he's the best and i'm so so grateful and
it's so beautiful to be able to watch
him you know step into this new role of
being a girl dad and he's
the best husband and best dad and i feel
so grateful every single day for him
i am so happy for you it's so wonderful
to hear
good people in the world
happy you know thank you happiness
is one of the greatest blessings
um and i am on a new mission
to really talk about the power of
forgiveness
what was the catalyst for you
to approach this subject and
put it at the forefront in this
extraordinary book well thank you
i mean i think that for me forgiveness
the interest in forgiveness really came
when i realized that i was really
struggling with forgiveness and my
inability to practice it
and i also didn't really know what it
meant to me and
it really just was so helpful to me to
be able to hear other people's
experiences
and to hear how people have struggled
with it and some still struggle with it
and
how some people have been able to
practice it and also we don't really
talk about it yet we all
will experience it at some point in our
lives and
i feel really lucky that it's been able
to be helpful for other people as well
there is something really for everyone
in this book and i just want to thank
you
for leading the charge on
helping people find an ability to do
such a courageous
important and liberating act and
i know you also partnered with the baby
probiotic
company and vivo is that how i pronounce
it
yeah vevo it's crazy because you know
when i think a lot about just being a
new mom
and teaching her about so many things
and also being taught
about so many things and one of the
things that i i learned about was
newborn gut deficiency which actually
impacts over 90 percent of babies born
in america
and that's just a lack of good bacteria
in babies guts and it's crazy because we
always hear about like
diaper rash and colic in newborn babies
and we think that's normal but the
reality is that has a lot to do with
just an imbalanced gut and so just being
able to
have the ability to work with a company
like avivo and
um give an infant probiotic is just
really incredible and i've had such a
great experience with it but it's like
one of those things that i want to share
with
all new moms to be able to research
about newborn gut deficiency but then
also just be able to give it to their
babies
and you have an instagram series before
during and after baby will you tell us
about that
yeah it's been so incredible i recently
did one with my mom
for mother's day which was hilarious um
but i
i've had such a great time doing it and
i um
it's all things before during after baby
so we
talk about everything from fertility to
pregnancy to
labor relationships sex
newborn gut deficiency really just all
the different topics that we want to
know more about and we have guts
guests come on and talk about all these
subjects and we do it every thursday at
noon and
it's been such a fun experience for me
and i'm learning
so much as a new mom so it's also really
beneficial that way
well thank goodness for that and also i
was so excited to talk about this book
and i know it's new out in paperback um
the gift of forgiveness inspiring
stories from those who have overcome
the unforgivable yeah thank you thank
you catherine schwarzenegger
we'll be right back thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this gorgeousness welcome back
i'm so excited to be sharing the kitchen
with not one but two of my favorite
people
first she's my culinary partner in crime
and co-author of our upcoming cookbook
rebel homemaker it's chef paular valdes
and next she's the founder of win coffee
supply america's first specialty
vietnamese coffee importer
and roaster she's also an incredible
activist who uses her platform to fight
for social
justice and racial justice please
welcome sarah wynn
back to the show thank you for having me
we've done so much in fact
we were talking before the segment pilar
made sarah a special surprise
yes i uh brought some um chili crisp i
took her coffee
out for a run and made a little chili
crisp and i brought it for her today
it looks amazing i cannot wait to try it
and then sarah's mom was kind enough to
make us her famous pork
and we got to eat it for lunch so thank
you
oh my god i'm gonna be so happy well
it's really nice to just have a family
vibe here
and sarah may is asian american and
pacific islander heritage month
and nobody is better to speak to this
than you
why is this so important that we pay
homage to this this month
first of all thank you so much for
creating the space drew so for
us apam or asian american pacific
islander heritage month is so
important to us because there's this
collective effort to humanize the asian
american experience
and like and over at one coffee supply
we're doing that by
using our platform to share stories from
our communities
to provide education around asian
american history
and to amplify asian american activists
well
you do
and you've been a really important
teacher on our show
and all over our digital and social
media
so you're just changing the narrative um
around
vietnamese coffee which i have been
sipping on and
i've always loved it with food
so pilar and i were talking and we were
like what about working with sarah
on a coffee cooking segment yeah i feel
like it was right after you had been on
the show
and i was like let's do recipes for
their coffee so we've come up
with not one not two but three
recipes and using coffee
so the first way we use sarah's coffee
actually
is as a spice rub so this one
is a grilled skirt steak and it has a
chili and coffee rub so in there
we have finely ground coffee and then to
that we're going to add some chili
flakes
some smoked paprika some ground cumin
and some brown sugar all right so you're
going to season that all over the steak
yeah add it in pack it in pack it in
there
so that looks really great drew so what
you're gonna do is pour some oil
um into the hot pan just a little bit
that's great and we're gonna sear off
the steaks oh my gosh
that cooks off and then we actually have
a little bit of a swap out
finished seared steak on the side and i
like to serve it
with a fennel and arugula salad so
shall we give it a try i'm so excited to
taste your beautiful coffee
oh my god that coffee smells really nice
it smells so good
wow oh my god
the spices in the coffee yeah that rub
is really really wonderful
no you're a genius all right shall we
next up yup next up
coffee roasted beets so we have a little
bit of coffee
we have fennel seeds cumin and so
all the spices are actually whole and
what i'm gonna do
is lay the beets in those coffee and
spices
and then we're gonna cover it with a
little bit of water and basically you're
gonna wrap it with foil
and roast it at a 375 degree oven for
about 45 minutes
and with the magic of television oh and
i love this with a salted yogurt sauce
shall we wow
um i couldn't love this dish more wow
so our last recipe for the day
um we're using brewed coffee yup and
it's in
a chocolate pot or a pot the creme
basically so
i know i'm ready i'm ready to just dig
in so
what um sarah has over there
with her house over there some egg yolks
and we're gonna um there's some sugar in
there as well and we're gonna whisk in
actually some of the brewed coffee
okay the whole thing yeah yeah so she's
gonna whisk that and then
she's gonna combine the egg mixture with
the chocolate mixture
the chocolate mixture in front of her is
just some warmed up heavy cream
and some chocolate that has been melted
and mixed through
and then sarah when that's combined
you're going to mix in
the softened butter the room temp butter
so you've got everything in the bowl and
you let that set for at least two hours
and we topped it with a little whipped
cream because why not are we
feeling it now yes absolutely burn up
[Music]
oh my god i'm dancing
you guys i think i just got weak in the
knees
this is insane thank you so much sarah
thank you pilar for blessing us for
these amazing recipes
cheers cheers cheers
[Applause]
for all three of these extraordinary
recipes and be sure to check out win
coffee supplies so you can get your
hands on this delicious coffee
we'll be right back
[Applause]
from aquaman to baywatch
really we just went down there to meet
ladies jason momoa
have your kids seen game of thrones oh
god
and i'm flying with an all-female crew
from the u.s
air force how do you feel about being
about 12 feet behind another aircraft
all new drew on the next
crew barrymore show
before we go it's time for another
check-in with the drew van
our road tripping couple noah and karen
have been making their way across the
country
from california and they'll be joining
us here in new york in a full
a few days but today they're helping us
surprise a very
special small business owner in
washington dc
there they are now but first let's meet
kathy
olefin wilson she's a veteran who
thought
outside the box and turned her passion
for giving presents
into a business with her company blush
boxes
that delivers curated gift boxes and
kathy is joining us now along with abc 7
reporter and our good friend of the show
kiddo shay
hi kids
[Laughter]
hi drew oh my god i can't believe i'm
meeting you
oh what a wonderful opportunity thank
you so much
i feel the exact same way and kid i'm
always happy to see you
great to see you again drew thank you
for having me back beautiful kathy
please tell me about your extraordinary
small business and how it came about
so drew i decided to start my business
about a year and a half ago right before
the onset of covet because i wanted to
utilize my gifts
my passions and my abilities to give
myself back into
back to the planet i really wanted to
make sure that i was operating in my
gift and transitioning from
my career to my calling i felt like it
was important for me to
again give my gifts and my talents to
people and to
help them deal with the stresses that
we're currently experiencing right now
absolutely incredible i love that we
would be
honored if you would join our little
book of smog businesses gift guide
if you go to the drewberrymore show.com
you'll be seeing kathy's
amazing blush boxes featured and then it
will live permanently
on our website for everyone to see and
go to
thank you so much how cool is that it's
so cool
by the way cassie have you heard about
our drew vann i sure have
noah and karen just pulled up with
something special for you
they are here look at that
[Laughter]
and it's a donation to plush boxes
the
hug curated we want to help continue to
make your business
the success it deserves to be and is
thank you so so very much oh my goodness
thank you
five thousand dollar check right behind
you all yours i can go back here
you can go back there go touch it thank
you
kid and kathy so much thank you so much
um and karen we'll see in new york soon
and to all of you at home
i hope you have a great rest of your day
take all of this goodness
with you it's for you and thank you for
joining us so much
we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you